tu es obligé de faire l'amour est-ce que
tu préfères faire l'amour avec Carlos tu
as acheté Carlos
ou Zaza le chien de Michel Drucker
tu as entendu parler des questions cons
[Musique]
comme ça pour se mettre pour se mettre
en train qu'est-ce que tu préfères
Dostoïevski Zulawski ou le whisky
maintenant que tu sois comme ce pauvre
je dis là le type qui a écrit les
versets sataniques qui est condamné à
mort par l'imam comeni il a dit il faut
tuer busy tous les musulmans du monde te
cherchent tu imagines tu vois le tableau
et tu décides de te faire refaire le
visage
ce qui serait dommage quand on te voit
d'ailleurs je peux te le dire est-ce que
tu te ferais refaire le visage comme
Denise Fabre comme Evelyne Leclerc ou
comme Marie-France Kubala
20h30
le plus plaisir à la radio à ma tante
réveillant la fin de l'apartheille la
mort de Pinochet ou TF1 a supprimé le
juste prix
[Musique]
tu préfères être coincé dans l'ascenseur
avec Johanna alliés Bernard-Henri Lévy
ou Philippe solaire
[Musique]
Bernard-Henri Lévy
du torse de la cheville et tout ça ça va
lui faire plaisir alors ce que tu
reproches le plus à Dieu d'avoir mis sur
Terre
les impuissants
les homosexuels ou les choses
on y va doucement
tu as rien contre les choses d'accord
alors maintenant tu sors un soin dans
une boîte même si c'est pas très
mondaine et puis tu rencontres un mec
génial vraiment c'est tu dis ça y est
c'est je craque c'est le coup de foudre
tu rentres avec lui et tu arrives chez
toi et tu as oublié un truc sur la table
de nuit qu'est-ce que c'est qui
t'emmerde aurait le plus vis-à-vis de ce
mec que tu veux absolument séduire bien
entendu ça serait d'avoir oublié un
godemichet ou mind camf
je te comprends alors maintenant tu es
obligé c'est un jeu tu es obligé de
faire l'amour
obligé t'es obligé tu as un flingue sur
la tente
prisonnières tu es obligé de faire
l'amour est-ce que tu préfères et faire
l'amour avec Carlos tu as acheté Carlos
ou Zaza le chien de Michel Drucker
te fâche pas avec Drucker je t'en prie
ta maison de disque te pardonnera jamais
de refuser le chien de Drucker alors
Zaza
tu iras loin c'est bien ça va faire
plaisir à Michel Drucker il va être très
content bon alors maintenant ton petit
ami c'est un petit ami
il a imagine ainsi il a des problèmes
bon il arrive pas trop à ça peut arriver
je suis arrivé à tout le monde bon alors
qu'est-ce que tu fais tu discutes en lui
disant comment elle s'appelle tu me
trompes je suis sûr qu'il y en a une
autre première solution deuxième
solution tu lui fais un truc spécial
troisième solution tu te casses
tu te casses
bon alors tu rencontres un mec le mec
génial de tout à l'heure j'ai oublié le
godemichet sur la tête de lit alors le
mec bon il est super il a un problème il
a le hoquet il parle sans arrêt où il
est très cochon qu'est-ce que c'est qui
t'emmerde le moi le hoquet il arrête pas
de parler au lit c'est un supportable
sans arrêt ou alors il est très très
cochon qu'est-ce que tu préfères
c'est drôle alors maintenant imagine que
tu achètes un perroquet
[Musique]
tu lui dis une phrase il la prend est-ce
que tu préfères lui a pour quelle phrase
tu lui apprendrais petit con petit con
est-ce que tu la prendrais buts a oublié
de fermer le gaz
ce qui est important est-ce que tu lui
apprendrais est-ce que le mec a mis sa
capote ou est-ce que tu la prendrais
coco arrête la coco
coco
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu